hey this is Lauren zagary with motion
sirens and today I'm going to share with
you how I organize all of my creative
projects
[Music]
quick disclaimer before getting into the
video after years of working in After
Effects professionally as a motion
designer the structure I'm about to show
you is the way that has worked for me
feel free to adapt any step to your own
projects and creative needs first let me
note the importance of staying organized
when it comes to your creative projects
having a streamlined way to work helps
you when you revisit projects and others
when you're part of a team of designers
people will thank you and you will thank
yourself later I'll start off by
showcasing the way I like to work for
most of my creative projects here is my
After Effects layout on the left hand
side is my project panel here I keep my
assets my compositions and my pre-comps
right under is the info panel where I
have access to color information from my
composition I like to keep my effects on
the left of my composition and
everything character related paragraph
aligned anchor points is on the right if
I need to track anything I like to have
my record panel right under my bike when
it comes to color I keep my Scopes
easily accessible and I need to use with
this out of the way let's see how we can
create a project when you first open up
after effects your project panel will be
empty here I'm going to go over the
folders I use in every single After
Effects project and how to make this a
template under the assets folder is
where I keep all my footage Illustrator
files audio CD renders images Photoshop
files and textures I like to keep my
main comps under the comps folder and
all pre-coms under the pretense form to
make sure this project opens up every
time we create a new project we can make
this a template first save your scene
then go to edit preferences and new
project here you can select the project
path take on new project loads template
and hit ok now let's go over were some
of my preference settings under General
I like to have Center Anchor Point in
u-shaped layer selected I also checked
on default spatial interpolation to
linear and synchronize time of all
related items under grids and guides I
like to make my proportional grid
horizontal 3 and vertical 3 to create a
rule of turns when it comes to label
colors I like to use red for text yellow
for footage green for any null control
layer and cyan for any background the
rest defaults when it comes to rendering
out of After Effects uncompressed files
I like to use a QuickTime format with
the Apple Perez 444 cover when it comes
to project structure out of After
Effects here's how I like to keep my
project organized I like to keep
everything related to the project
whether it's PDFs or Creator briefs
Hindi documents the projects folder is
dedicated to all my project files if I
open it I have the folder for After
Effects one for blender one for element
3D one for Premiere and another one is
for purest where I keep all my new
phones the media folder this is where I
keep all assets related to my project
everything I import into After Effects
will be in the com access folder while
anything reference will go into the
footage or image folder if I end up
exporting any textures or comps outside
of after effects for any given project
it will be in these three renderers
folder any final export goes into these
renders folders I recommend suiting this
folder structure someplace handy on your
computer so you can copy and paste it
whenever you start a new project
now let's get into naming conventions I
took some time to build this composition
with two three comps inside one main car
before anything let me start off by
saying that I don't do a lot of vector
animation so I usually don't deal with
massive scenes with hundreds of layers
and character animation tricks for
example I like to keep things simple and
organized for the work I like to create
one general rule of thumb I like to
abide by when I name comes and three
comps and various layers is to use the
Straight bar character as a separator
for my main comp I usually type in main
then the street bar character and then
the cloud name when it comes to
freecoming backgrounds and shape layers
I usually type in gfx for graphics than
the straight bar character the layer
names Trad bar character again and PC
for pre-comp when it comes to text
pre-com I usually like to type in text
than the straight white character than
the text player name Street Bar
character and PC for pre-con I like to
keep these elements in their own
respective folders for easy access and
overall organizations one last thing I
want to mention when it comes to project
structure and overall organization is to
start creating an asset library for your
footage and textures having an organized
folder structure where you keep your
textures and footage makes tackling
projects much less daunting knowing
where certain textures are located on
your computer or what pieces of footage
can you use and reuse will make the
process of getting what's in your head
onto the software much quicker having a
library makes it so you don't have to go
through the steps of searching for the
right textures every time trust me I've
been there when it comes to assets you
don't need every single tag that's out
there all you need is the right ones you
keep going back to and make sure the
reversal enough to use them in a variety
different projects I also recommend
keeping it organized by categories for
example static versus moving footage and
different folders of size paper grunge
glass film textures and so on one last
Pro tip for you today is to always use
high quality assets for your projects
using high quality assets gives you the
Leisure of scaling and positioning
textures as you please without the
quality constraint I hope you like this
video and learned something new today if
you want to share the way you structure
your work leave it in the comments below
until next time this is Lauren zagary
with motion science
foreign
[Music]